today I'm going to present my work on
new law accounts and journalization for
180 and the other migration Center
review on the arithmic method
that's a plan for today's talk
first I'm going to
review the background on circular bounds
and the algorithmic method then I'll
talk about a result
um generalization Centric perspective on
the algorithmic method finally I will
briefly talk about the technical
ingredients and the proof overview
let's start with the background
so here
is Amplified history and motivation for
pulling circular bonds so since the
1980s people wanted to prove MP not
equal to that's not equal to P we are
putting lower bounds for stronger and
stronger okay classes
and the ultimate goal is to prove MPS
not in P slash poly where pslash poly
denotes our polynomial size circuits so
first people look at a much weaker
version of second class called ac0 which
is the constant depth and or not
circuits where the end or not have
unbounded value
so I'm stamina now I've worked prove
that the parity function is hard for 80
zero circuits
so the next goal is to
consider stronger as a care class so
people just ate parity parity into 80
zero and consider parity two which is
ac0 extended with priority grades and
then
using the polynomial method when power
offense models key proves that mod 3 is
hard for h02
so here what p is the function which
output 1 if and only if P does not
divide the number of ones in the input
so
naturally the next goal is to add mod 3
into the second class and consider a
slightly larger secure classes
and that's 806 which is X no expanded
with most six Gates
I mean what six is equivalent to have
both mod 2 and mode switch
so this is zero six if it's a zero
expanded with more six Gates and it's
obtained by adding parity and mode 3
into 8-0
it seems it shouldn't be much stronger
than a little parity and the people
believed it might be possible to prove
lower bounds against Exodus 6. now
unfortunately it has been opened for
10 for two decades whether even asked
the non-seministic exponential type
contains functions that cannot be
computed by polynomial size as
a06 circuits of step three
and the progress basically stops
together here until
2011 our Williams proved that an X does
not have polynomial size a to zero
circuits
and the
similar to ac06 we use ac0m to denote
constant depth polynomial size and or
not mod M gate circuits
and the 83 0 is simply the union of ac0n
for our constants m
so after Williams work
muri and R Williams prove that and
killed and QP
non-deterministic classy polynomial time
does not have polynomial size a to the
zero circuit which greatly improve the
the
complexity class NX to nqp
and later Chang and learn following some
previous work proved that mqp cannot be
destroyed cannot be half plus one over
polynomial approximated by polynomial
size into the zero circuits thereby
improving the worst case law upon 2 a
strongly average case lower bound
and later Chan Lee and Williams proved
that if the MP cannot be half past what
two to the minus infinity or one
approximated by 2 to the N to the
with the o1 size is the zero circuit for
us sufficiently large influences thereby
proving the first almost everywhere
lower bound
against 80 circuits
so in this talk in English work will
give alternative proofs for the first
two results and some new results
the Williams original proof is kind of
interact in the sense that it's
essentially at its heart approved by
contradiction
and a very very rough summary is that
you assume that the light lower bound is
false for example you assume that an X
is contained in h0 and then you you
contradict the end time the non-thematic
time hierarchy series
meaning that the lower bound must be
true
and see the full version of this paper
for a detailed presentation of Williams
original proof
and all motivation is that can we have
unlocked direct proof of course these
questions cannot vague the intuitively
want to avoid any improved by
contradiction that's our motivation and
such a proof might be easier to
to understand
so
next let's move to our result
here is the road map for showing mklp
not in 820 following or the
randomization Centric perspective
so first I'm going to
prove through a lower Bound for a
certain subclass of M A here I may
denotes money as well Focus which I'm
going to Define in a moment against http
0. and next we are going to de-randomize
this subcast of ma into mqp
then then we'll have a highly language
in mkop against HTT which is exactly
what we want
so we begin by the first step a lower
Bound for a subcast of ma against HD
zero we first recall the definition of m
a which is a randomized version of MP so
we say a language L is in MA if that is
that polynomial time uniform algorithm v
such that given an input X the guess is
done with this Y and tosses some coins
are and we require that if x is in L
then that exists uh witness why such
that we accept the probability at least
two-thirds
and then you've actually accessed
nothing else then for every y the
probability of of we accept a random R
is at the most well-third
and we use m a sub c to denote the
subclass of MMA such that V admit
polynomial size non-uniform three
circuits
so we think about ma sub c as a subclass
of M A where the verifier V is is
efficient in a sense that admits uh C
implementation
and uh
first result says that for every
constant K and makes up a to zero has no
into the case size it is zeros for tips
and for the second step we want to add
randomization of ma sub H 0 into mqp
will just use a recently result by churn
B and Williams
so Assurance One Channel and Williams
states that Ma sub s a 0 is contained in
infinitely alphan mkop
in other words it says that for every
language l in MA sub a C 0 there is a
language L Prime in nqp such that for
infinitely many influences and L and a
prime agreed on MP inputs
so for our first result we know that Ma
sub 8 0 is hard for H 0 and the from the
previous work by children Williams we
can de randomize and make sub Exit 0
into nqp
so intuitively combining them together
we should have nklp if not in X zero
however life and issue requires infinite
after an issue
so and the
the caveat here is that if you look at
the statement precisely the first result
says that
that's a language l in MA sub s0 such
that for infinitely many influences in L
is hard and empty inputs for X is zero
and the the serum one says that for
every language l in Ma at zero Delta L
Prime such that for infinitely many N L
and L Prime
equals embed inputs
the problem so our plan is to take a
high language run without one in a sub
at a zero and der randomized into
another language L Prime hope and hope
that L Prime is still hard against at
least zero but this does not work as we
expected because
because
what if
L and L Prime only agrees and inputs
that L is not hard but because we only
know when our plan agrees and if the
setup of influences and the L you've had
another infinite set of influences so
it's very possible that these two steps
are actually disjoint and L Prime do not
inclare it in and do not retain the
hardness of L and that's a big problem
so how do we love this issue we'll use
ideas for murian Williams
so what we'll do is that we will
strengthen both without wine and
steering one so that the two relevant
set
so the first step is
all the input lenses such that L is hard
for it is zero from without one and the
second set is other influences such that
L and L Prime agrees on
will strengthen those results so that
these two sets have an infinite size
intersection so you and we can guarantee
that then a point is going to agree with
illness in many input lenses where you
know it's actually hard against H to the
zero so L Prime is going to be hard
against X zero as well
and let's see the full version of its
paper for more details
the following is New Perspective we not
only obtain some alternative proofs for
other results we also obtained some new
results
so first we have an improved lower
balance for NX against acetate zero
so we didn't prove that an act has no
steps third exponential size is a little
circuits and we improve the lower bound
to be an X has no sub half exponential
size it is zero circuits so here we see
a function we see a side function s of n
to be sub half exponential if s of s of
n is Select sub-exponential and then we
say it is subscribe exponential if s of
s of n is so half cell exponential
and see the full version flat
what precise definition
and we also obtain new generalizations
for a to zero
so the previous work by Chengdu and
William the randomized and made 86 0
into non-steministic proof systems with
quasi polynomial time
and the classic polynomial problems
because the only issue ma sub ha0 is
contained in Infinity often and QP
and we improve the proof length to the
polynomial
but running time is still quantity
polynomial so that is we show every ma
sub xs0 proof system can be
de-randomized into a non-diseministic
food system with quantity polynomial
running time and the polynomial
non-terminism bits
and making use of this new
generalization we also prove that mqp
with super polynomial non-steminism
beats is strongly average case hard
against exit 0. this improves previous
work by wires and the chain energy
again see the full version of the paper
for more details
and finally I'm going to briefly talk
about the technical ingredient and give
a proof overview
so recall that we want to approve our
result
when that Ma sub Exit 0 has no into the
case size as a little circuit in fact we
are going to prove a
more General result nothing more formal
that
for most circuit Class C we have for
every constant K and makes the ac0
parity of C has no into the case size C
circuits note that
a300 is closed undertaking up it is our
party at the top so this implies what we
want
and uh and what is is the parity of C so
so figurative speaking you have a top a
zero parity circuit whose input are the
output of a layer of three sub circuits
so so that so you have a layer of three
sub circuits at the bottom and each of
each of the output one bit and we have a
top s0 party circuit which is going to
take other outputs of those three
sockets as input and then output another
bit
and the previous work
shows that
shows a very similar result but uh but
uh
for ma sub tc0 of C
has no mpk size three circuits
so here tv0 is constant that polynomial
size circuits consisting entirely of
majority Gates
parity to prove without one
and uh
why the previous work has to use tc0 in
the maverifier
so roughly speaking the previous work
uses a piece-based company language with
that T30 instance checker
so what is the instance checker so we
say a language L is seamless instance
checkable it relies that polynomial time
Oracle machine M such that first on an
input X are purely made by m twit Oracle
has the same length as X
second
if m is given the correct Oracle when
you have to give m is given access to l
um and embed inputs then and output L of
X with probability one
and uh for every possible X and all
possible Oracle M outputs
that so M either outputs the correct
answer or I'll put a faded symbol with
probability as it is two-thirds
so think about the end is trying to
check the whether the Oracle is
actually computes L sub n so the second
property is that if m is given the
correct Oracle then it's going to be
correct
and the third probability is that no
matter what Oracle and it's given like
it can be given an arbitrary garbage
Oracle and it's not going to Output a
wrong answer with high probability so if
it's going if you get some like a random
Oracle Tomatoes output as failure symbol
and we say l is saying Since checkable U
M can be implemented by a family of a
non-adaptive state Oracle circuits
so the previous work proves
the ma sub tc0 of C has no into the case
side States look at the lower Bound by
using a piece based by giving a p-speed
complete language that is tc0 instance
checkbook
so we now will briefly
explain how the how the how the language
and may substitute the value of C is
constructed to recall the definition of
Ma so
so you sorry for a language L to being M
A that has to be a polynomial time
uniform algorithm V which takes that
input X gets something since Y and
plotted some coins
and the verifier V of the hard and may
substitutes area of C language works and
photos
first it treats the witness Y at the
polynomial size C circuit require C sub
y
and then it runs the instance Checker of
L with the system y as the oracle
and the output and its output is
basically just the result of the
instance checker
so as you can see the overall complexity
is running with the instance Checker
with a Oracle implementable implemented
with an Oracle in C so the other
capacity is strength tc0 off C
so Oracle has to improve the TD level
tc0 above to 180 parity and then we can
pull without one and that's exactly what
we did
we
we show that that P space complete
language L that is Exit 0 instance
checkable and it's also 80 downward
self-reducible it's 0 weekly error
correctable and compatible
I'm not going to define the last three
properties but they are also useful in
the proof
and by plugging the language above into
the previous pool we can get without one
and the construction of the Pittsburgh
this P space can be languages very
complicated so I don't have time to go
over the details but you are welcome to
check the full version of the paper for
more details
thanks